paris hilton is officially engaged to
carter reim
he's my perfect match he really is just
so incredible so supportive loyal kind
brilliant and i look up to him so much
the heiress announced the big news just
after valentine's day on february 17th
her 40th birthday posting these pics to
instagram
alongside the caption when you find your
soulmate you don't just know it
you feel it i'm so lucky just the
relationship i have
the birthday girl added that carter
popped the question on a tropical
getaway after a walk along the beach
that led to a cabana filled with flowers
quote
i said yes yes to forever there's
no one i'd rather spend forever with
paris also shared details from the
special moment on her website
writing quote it was the kind of
proposal i had always dreamed of
followed by a special celebration with
family and close friends
the simple life star also shared a
stunning video of her engagement ring
design
hand-painted in the atelier of jean
ducey
the great-great-grandson of louis
francois cartier
translation this ring is very
very fancy he's always giving me
business advice
and is just so just caring and romantic
and we just have the best time together
the lovebirds celebrated their first
anniversary as a couple in december
paris paid tribute to her man on the
milestone day on instagram
writing in part i have never felt so
close to another person
in my life and that's because you're the
first one who tore down the walls i
built around my heart
and opened up my heart in a way that i
didn't know was possible
thank you paris was previously engaged
to model jason shaw
heir paris latsis and most recently in
2018
actor chris zilka which she called off
later that year
in september 2020 she opened up to et
about how she knows carter is the one
i was never really open to a
relationship because i wasn't
ready to open my heart just because of
what i had been through
so i never let anyone fully in until now
and now i am just so excited
for that next step and to get married
and have babies
and just finally be hap
as happy as i always wished
you